i just thought it was weird but it's
supposed to be a social group activity
yeah like you don't go to the movies by
yourself is what i cause you're a crazy
person yeah it's just like or you're
lonely or you have no friends like
what's wrong i wonder if it's an
extrovert introvert thing
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to big moves
welcome who do we have here today
jess
and nikki
but switch those voices
and i'm tiff thank you for joining us
once again on this beautiful evening
we've started this episode very
sensually yeah unnecessary not a sensual
episode no i started like channeling
talk radio
that's what i was trying to do like some
advice is because what was that lady's
name that she was she hosted the like
sunday night whatever
you're listening to big mood podcast
there we go on 92 9 fm
all right the kids don't even know what
that means
i know does anyone listen to the radio
anymore call satellites
there's radio if you're a gen z leave in
the comments if you know what fm and am
radio is okay that's relevant because
this is all advice from millennials to
gen zers oh wait no no yeah this is a
different one no it's not that episode
but look out for that episode
later that's coming later now this
episode um we're gonna be talking about
healthy behaviors that people are often
shamed for oh
yeah so it's so someone asked on reddit
what is a healthy behavior that people
shame others for
and a lot of these are pretty common and
i don't know i thought it was pretty
interesting so like maybe we should feel
less guilty for these things and for
some reason society typically makes us
feel bad exactly this type of behavior
yeah when it's like a genuinely like
healthy kind of like normalize this type
of right okay so i'll give you the first
one so an example here is doing
something you enjoy but being bad at it
oh you know it's like you're enjoying it
live your life you're perfect yeah
that's mickey's brand new yeah is it
like do you think is it like who makes
people feel bad
because the only time i can think of it
is like if someone has too much like
ego ego
and they're not good at it then you
could see kind of like people around
them being like you're not even good at
it so [ __ ] off but i feel like most
people i know would be like well she's
trying yeah yeah but do you think that
you've
if it's put on the internet there's
always going to be weird haters for
those reasons they're just like no
matter what find me like yeah
who are you and why are you commenting
on my life did you put a key word i
didn't put seo in this yeah
let's find this
yeah that's true because yeah that's how
you started your tasty tuesday did you
feel you came across a lot of that oh
yeah but only when they went viral
because it was like
and when they went viral a lot because
people are looking up cooking videos and
like sometimes weirdly like a dish will
trend two years later or whatever and
then you get like a random wave of
haters because you're not making the
dish right or whatever um but yeah i
started tasty tuesday because i wanted
to learn how to cook having never had
step foot in a kitchen really
had didn't know that you're supposed to
prep ingredients before you start
cooking so i would literally be like the
burner would be on and it's like add the
garlic and i'm like oh i gotta peel this
how do i say that
oh my god it's burning this is literally
my life right now video is like that's
how you learn to do this
and i learned because there would be
comments nice comments telling me oh
you're actually supposed to do this
beforehand yeah oh this is how you get
it peeled oh this is the end yeah and
then there were people that were like oh
my god i'm so glad he poses this because
i relate and i didn't know that that
that you're supposed to use this way to
peel garlic until i read your comments
so it was like a group learning together
and then people that know how to cook
you know helping right and it took five
years but eventually like i pretty much
know how to cook now yay
that's awesome yeah you probably cook
best out of all of us yeah so started
comedically because like i know i'm
gonna be bad so it's just like make fun
of the process but i was also having fun
yeah i think that's the thing people are
missing is the having fun part like it
shouldn't be about like being good right
away you're not gonna be good at right
away like you're not supposed to be good
when you're a beginner you know i just
recently experienced this i know you
guys were um making fun of me because
i'm on a company volleyball today
um but i was just picturing that ass
yeah so well i was in full on it was
cold so i wasn't like full-on sweatpants
so i
found myself like tagging out to like
sit out and watch because i was like oh
i'm not good like but then everyone was
like no one cares about this league like
it's just for fun yeah you know and
other people that we're still staying in
and not doing well and like losing
points for the team and stuff like that
and just having fun with it but i was
like
ah but we're like so close to winning
that i feel like if i just stay out
maybe we can win
but so i don't there's a i guess there's
a line where it's like just enjoy
yourself anyway because that's the point
but also i kind of was like ah if i come
to the competitive side yeah i was like
right now ever like because it was the
first time i had ever played volleyball
i've never
never played volleyball it's cool that
you signed up for it yeah yeah never
even touched a volleyball i don't know
the rules i don't know anything about it
like the day that we started like we
showed up and i was like what are the
rules they're like oh well you can't hit
it more than three times before you hit
it back and like just telling me all
this stuff and i was like okay i don't
remember anything you just said but then
so we just started but i felt kind of
bad i was like i don't want to do it
because i don't know if they're gonna
think like why did we let her on the
team you know but this is why i like you
this is the only reason okay
now i have to commend you because i feel
like you do get out of your comfort zone
for someone with so high anxiety
needs to know how everything works and
control everything yeah like you do get
out of your comfort zone a lot like you
didn't even want to be on a podcast or
any form of in front of the camera work
and you thought you were bad at it and
you thought you would ruin the show if
you were on yeah all kinds of stuff and
now look at you you're like so good and
people love you and you bring so much to
show and so like it's funny because
you'll say things like i have to sit in
the same airplane seat every time or
whatever
yeah but then you're like oh yeah i just
signed up randomly for a volleyball team
and i've never played volleyball like
that's actually scary and so that's yeah
so good though i was super nervous
before i
got there to the very first game and
then once i got there and it was so
chill and i was like what was i so
worried about yeah it was fine well you
know that you're
but you're still able to get past it and
do it
i for the most part for me like it's i
can't get over that hump like i need to
be a perfectionist person like that's
why like recently like especially in the
kitchen like i'm just like all right you
know what i gotta let this part of me
yeah like it's it's holding me back and
it's annoying like it's
tortillas right so then i made like i
made this like mexican bread and it
actually didn't help me to
like get over this hump for the next
thing because i nailed it i made it
perfectly yeah i was like [ __ ] like
now like the expectations are higher for
the next time i kind of wanted to fail a
little bit so then i could like
the expectations for you or for everyone
that's gonna like
you know like your family that's gonna
eat um mainly for me because i'm my
biggest like judgmental person on me
like i yeah i'm afraid of my judgment
the most because i'm so judgmental
towards myself and so like i kind of
wanted to fail a little bit so then the
next time i'm like see i got i got
through that but then i [ __ ] killed
it so hard then i'm like damn it's in
your jeans
you can't be mexican and not know how to
cook it just doesn't it's like so
embedded into your dna that i don't
think it matters like so funny there's
no way you can fail just keep trying
yeah well you're gonna you're gonna
realize how good of a cook you really
are yeah you were just holding me
telling me that i keep like executing
really well like those like meal prep
delivery stuff like every time i cook
the chicken like chicken breasts it's
hard it's always the juiciest like what
like the best chicken breast casey's
ever eaten
yeah it's still tender and i'm like
really i just i don't know i just
followed
great chicken breasts
no but yeah so anyway so yeah just being
just doing something even if you're bad
at it right yeah it's like just enjoy it
like that's a healthy thing like you
know you don't have to worry about being
perfect and that's how you learn like
you said like you wish you failed a
little bit i wish more people embraced
that mentality of like oh if i mess up
i'll learn something yeah
there's sometimes though where i'm like
you're really bad at this and you
shouldn't do this and this one of my
ex-boyfriends he thought he was a rapper
like he was going to become a rapper
like legitimately i'm not even kidding
like that was his plan a and he didn't
have a plan b whoa and so like we would
go out and then he would start to get
kind of drunk towards the other night
and and i remember i would be driving us
home and he'd start rapping in the car
right and i was like oh this is hell
yeah like this is literal hell so he was
not good at it he wasn't good at it and
i'm like
but i think it's because he was so
like sure of himself yeah like he was
like he knew that he was the [ __ ] and he
was like rapping in the car and tell him
he was like he was like yo girl listen
to this check this out
duh oh my gosh oh [ __ ] that's good even
though i gotta write that down
and then i would just be sitting there
like oh my god someone [ __ ] kill me
like just kill me like you later pretty
good
yeah when he was like when it was like
when he would get drunk and then like
turn into this like rapper kanye person
all of a sudden oh was he me
yeah
he was like when nikki turns into eminem
and it just like
turn it off and it takes three three
things and i'm like all right we're
doing this karaoke eminem oh yeah so it
was like that but he was for serious and
that was his life oh my goodness um and
he's still not a rapper and he still
doesn't mean
and so yeah so sometimes when when
people say like you're bad at this you
shouldn't do it but i think it's
probably just the like maybe it's the
level of like community that you put
into it like how much does it rule your
life but you know that saying ignorance
is bliss i'm jealous of that you know
because some people can hear criticism
and still be like nah [ __ ] you like yeah
you haters i'm a [ __ ] dopest rapper
and maybe he's still in that world like
i'm [ __ ] sick yeah he's like you know
someone so didn't make it till they were
45 so i've got another eight years to go
and i'm like i god bless you because
you're way happier than me
they're so happy
yeah i know this girl who
similar things she's like i'm an actress
i'm an actress
and she
like does skits and stuff and she can
not even sell a sentence like it's yeah
she's very like is that the car like
yeah
you're like turn it off like whatever
you're turning on just turn it off and
talk yeah
she'll just she keeps like posts and she
loves it she thinks she's really really
good and she talks about like acting in
the crowd she's able to get jobs i mean
someone's liking it
yeah yeah yeah and so i i always look at
her and i'm like i wish i had that
i wish i had that yeah
that kind of looks like i beat myself up
probably too much and like you know me
and you were it's just like oh like i
never feel competent enough yeah yeah
but honestly your life is really your
life so if you're enjoying something
even if you're bad at it um you'll just
get a new girlfriend
[Music]
that's just gonna happen
so just keep doing what you love you
imagine him with some girl right now
who's like oh that was sick yeah exactly
yeah did you write that down yeah yeah
that's who he needs yeah and then i i
feel like i just keep dating guys like
that where i'm just like
this is really bad and they're just like
you just don't understand my art you
know i'm just like [ __ ] i'm a dream
killer because i'm just
i'm like no this [ __ ] is bad
don't write that down don't do it
anymore
all right the next one on this list it
says taking a healthy amount of time to
take care of yourself rest or recoup
rest shouldn't be a reward it should be
treated as a necessary aspect of life
because you know people get shamed for
like taking like a day off or like
they'll even shame themselves they'll be
like oh i wasn't productive like damn i
just i had a lazy sunday [ __ ] why did i
why didn't i do this on
this day or whatever i am people yes
girl you relate
it's been like a really big uh pendulum
swing though where i'm like am i napping
too much now
should i be doing you're finally resting
from that like decade of overlapping
yeah that's true
um i don't know i feel like maybe that's
more of a corporate world thing because
i i've realized over the last like kind
of almost decade that i've been in the
youtube world over here in california
like we do stuff and there's hustle
culture or whatever but it's not the
same like yes maybe you'll be filming
and doing stuff for long hours but then
it's just like it it's an easy life
still you know what i mean like you can
of course pack your day to have too much
[ __ ] going on but that compared to like
working in a nine to five where it's
like literally feels like slavery kind
of in time certain times where that
would like and you're not in control of
like well i can't take a nap for an hour
yeah now and then go film again like how
we do like some of those other jobs so
then everyone who's also like stockholm
syndrome with their coworkers and stuff
they're like you took a whole saturday
off like yeah you know you didn't do
anything else you know so when people
especially in the corporate world where
they're they'll kind of shame you for
taking vacation time yeah where it's
like wait what like i'm literally
probably not your co-workers but
probably like your bosses like the
company culture yeah it could be a
company culture of that where it's like
wait like you have vacation days that
you're actually cashing in like we don't
do that yeah
oh sorry go ahead oh you can go ahead
and speak
i've also heard it's an american thing
yeah yeah in spain they take siestas
they like
in japan they got nuts with their work
culture oh yeah where they had to like
force people to like you need to take
time off like this yeah insane yeah i
think some european countries maybe like
more spanish
they yeah they're more for down for the
cs
like paris and some of the other
countries because like i see the
forums in my industry and they're
working 60 70 hours a week too like
they're not they're not like [ __ ]
chilling like everyone's in paris yeah
but like in my industry they're working
hell hours yeah france is the one that
gets uh branded as the lazy ones yeah
maybe that's like uh other
industry lit tired yeah remember that do
you hear that video like the
do you remember that video with like the
bombs and stuff and like it's about the
end of the world where there's nuclear
bombs going off they're like fire are
they misses and then he's like i'm
little no
like everyone dies except for california
oh wow hawaii no but yeah in france
though they each meal is like hours long
yeah hours because i was reading an
article this was back in oh god i'm
really dating myself this episode so we
used to not have youtube videos we had
like magazine articles that we read
yeah back in the year
in cosmopolitan they still exist okay i
don't know who's buying them i don't
know who's buying them either at least
the physical ones anyway i remember
specifically reading an article about
how french women stay thin and they were
talking about how the meals take a long
time even though they're eating butter
and croissants and all that stuff
they're like yeah they thoroughly chew
each bite and like they they cut and
they put the utensils down like in
between bites like as they're chewing
they like put it down yeah they're just
like slopping it yeah it's also smaller
portions and smaller portions also they
smoke cigarettes so they don't have so
much of an appetite and they drink wine
yeah lots of coffee yeah lots of coffee
stimulants yeah you guys have all heard
of purple mattress right if you're
sleeping on a terrible mattress your
sleep will be terrible that's why i
recommend the purple mattress
i don't have the purple mattress myself
but someone whose house i stay over at
night does have a purple mattress and i
do love it one thing i do have though is
a pillow they sent us a pillow to try
out and i use it in my living room it's
got the gel flex grid on it i sometimes
like to lay there watch tv and i just
kind of like squishy squishy the pillow
with my fingers because i love the
feeling of the gel grid it's like a
really cool feeling you have to try it
at least once in your life give it a
shot unlike memory foam which remembers
everything the gel flex grid bounces
back as you move and shift you'll never
have that i'm stuck feeling people get
with memory foam try purple mattress
risk free with free shipping and returns
and financing is available too getting a
great night's sleep starts with having a
great mattress get a purple mattress go
to purple.com big move 10 and use code
big mood 10. for a limited time you can
get 10 off any order of 200 or more
that's purple.com big mood 10 code
bigmood10 for 10 off any order of 200 or
more one last time purple.com
10 and use our promo code big mood 10
for 10 off terms apply when my cats are
healthy they are happy and that makes me
super happy but since i'm not a mind
reader i don't always know when they're
healthy helping me know that both of my
kitties are healthy is just one of the
reasons that i love using pretty litter
pretty litter's ultra absorbent crystals
trap odor instantly so there's no more
cat bathroom smell pretty litter's super
light crystal base also minimizes mess
and dust plus the crystals last up to a
month which means less scooping and
fewer trips to the garbage can the
coolest thing about pretty litter is
that it changes color to help me detect
early signs of potential illness in my
cats including urinary tract infections
and kidney issues and pretty litter
ships free to my door in a small
lightweight bag and i never run out of
it so i don't have a huge container of
litter taking up space and stinking up
my place i honestly love pretty litter
i've been using it for quite some time
now and i just love how it doesn't have
that chalky dust that you tend to have
with traditional like conventional
litter pretty litter is like so clean no
dust it also absorbs all of the urine so
i just have to scoop up the poop and
it's super easy to maintain my kitty
litter boxes especially with two cats so
pretty litter helps keep my cats healthy
and keeps odor down you and your cat are
going to love pretty litter as much as
we do so go to prettylitter.com and use
code big mood for 20 off your first
order that's pretty litter.com code big
mood for 20 off prettylitter.com code
big mood all right next one being slow
to respond i would rather respond
correctly than quickly same for
confidence level if i am unsure it means
i want to double check it seems more
irresponsible to speak off the cuff but
i think the reality is that the fast
talkers are rewarded more
even if they're wrong that's me
so the [ __ ] answer will help my habit
here is to be slow to respond like take
your time think about it and people get
shamed for it
yeah well i guess there's a difference
between people not responding and
seeming like they're not engaging or
like not trying or just blowing it off
and so those people kind of
if they're not gonna put you know like a
note on it like oh can i take a couple
hours or a couple of days to think this
over and get back to you like i guess if
you're proactive and saying i'm i am
working on this and i am thinking about
it but like people like me
i will just [ __ ] word vomit and i
will have an answer and i'll probably
convince you that it's the right answer
just and it works for me like it gets me
places yeah so confidence sells it the
confidence tells it so i can see how
someone who's like i'm not really sure
like they're going to get blocked i'm
going to i'm going to get it i'm going
to steamroll them i'm going to get in
front of them and it may not even be
based on merit it's just i can sell it
yeah that's what the world is about
though is selling [ __ ] that's true
nobody knows anything nobody knows
anything yeah things out of their ass
and then they're like that worked all
right yeah
move on people liked
a lot of people get in trouble too yeah
well
same so i had to really slow my roll
because you know in comedy like you're
just like improving and stuff like that
but then i realized actually on jk news
that like my brain will latch on to
something i heard like
10 years ago like someone randomly said
like it takes i'm really good at trivia
because like a random [ __ ] just pops in
my head from things that were said but i
never like looked to see if they were
correct it's just something that i
picked up and then it was got stored in
my memory and then when someone says a
trigger word about that it opens a file
of everything i know about that thing
and whatever's in there i just grab it
and i say it and it comes out of my
mouth and then people were like that's
actually not true i'm like you're
probably right like i'm not going to
bite you i just like didn't think about
it he's like did you know i didn't check
it nick he's like did you know if you
swallow a watermelon see the watermelon
will grow in your stomach and you get
back to it it's not amazing that humans
can do that
everyone's like
no that's not true and no one says
anything in the room they're like that's
not true it's not until afterwards i
feel like you dumbass yeah [ __ ]
watermelon you stupid [ __ ] why didn't
you shut up and then i'm like oh and
google it like i don't know why that was
in there but i'll take it out now like
i'll take it out of the file i will
formally remove this piece i'm not
attached to the information when you're
giving this piece of information it's
like with the utmost confidence yeah
this is correct because it got stored in
there
yeah yeah because then like i'll do
something similar but for me it's the
the complete opposite of the spectrum of
confidence where it's like i have this
piece of like this fact or whatever
but i'm not for sure that it is a fact i
didn't fact check it myself so i'm going
to tell you i don't know but i think i
heard this you're like maybe i made this
up i don't know i don't remember but
here you're just saying i don't actually
know but yeah yeah because before it was
just like oh did you hear that
and people were like really i'm like
yeah
crazy huh they're like really that's
funny because this says no like oh okay
let me change it
and then someone else i say it later
they're like no it actually is true like
all right
i'm putting it back
that's funny all right next one doing
things that are normally thought of as
social activities by yourself like
eating at a restaurant or going to a
concert play or a movie oh yeah people
think i'm so weird for that yes steve
shamed me for this because he was like
so weird like people that just go eat
alone and i'm like
i eat alone like eat it alone at a
restaurant or what go watch me do that
i've been at your house where he would
leave for like two hours
he would go to that mexican restaurant
or
he's cheating
i think maybe i opened his mind up too
because um it was like when we first
started dating and his best friend went
to a movie alone and he got offended
because he wanted to see the movie with
him he was like why didn't he just wait
for me why didn't he invite me why
didn't i was like sometimes you just
want to see a movie alone and he's like
that's weird like why do people do that
and i'm like i don't think it's that
weird i mean that was literally me and
casey cause like early on too he'd be
like oh yeah i'm gonna go watch a movie
i'm like so
uh like with me or like what he's like
oh i'm just gonna go alone i'm like
that's [ __ ] weird like why are you
gonna go do you feel by yourself you're
being rejected
um
i just thought it was weird but it's
supposed to be a social group activity
yeah like you don't go to the movies by
yourself because you're a crazy person
yeah it's just like or you're lonely or
you have no friends like what's wrong i
wonder if it's an extrovert introvert
thing i think so because then afterwards
after he did that i'm like you know what
i want to try this out like what is this
like going to the theater by yourself
like what is how does that feel so i
went to the movies by myself and i
watched a scary movie i think it was
jennifer's body or something and i was
like okay
all right
interesting
this is cool i get it like just suppose
you're really with myself like who cares
you're like you can't talk to anyone
anyway you know what it's like it's like
when you went to bora bora by yourself
it feels like i'm not supposed to be
here by myself
like you're like ditching yeah something
that's like skipping out on the world
yeah like when i went to vegas to make
an offer on the house steve couldn't
come with me and so i randomly flew to
vegas
early in the morning by myself rented a
car by myself was driving through vegas
by myself i had never been to vegas
alone before
and i was like i'm not supposed to be
here
yeah and then i played poker by myself
and then i went and made an offer on a
house by myself and i was like what is
they just let me out in the world
that's how i feel all the time now
no like for me it felt freeing though it
felt really like i couldn't understand
why people enjoy it because i like that
was the first time like that movie
theater experience i think was the very
first time i actually spent time alone
with me
and i'm like oh i enjoy my own company
yeah i understand why people like being
alone now that's why that trip to bora
bora like the whole time i'm like oh my
god i don't have to like like i don't
have to work with someone else to figure
out what to eat or what to do next i get
to decide by myself yeah like this is
cool yeah so yeah like i totally get it
now yeah just doing things by yourself
it's it's healthy like once you get okay
with it then you actually really like it
yeah it's like a little break from the
world yeah yeah there is like a like a
little hump to get over it yeah it's
kind of like i'm awkward i don't know
what to do
are people looking at me right now like
what is i don't know like do i have a
booger or something like it just feels
weird
but then once you get over that little
hump like it just feels very freeing and
then you realize like no one gives a
[ __ ] about no no people don't care about
you no one cares they're not even
looking at you like is she ditching yeah
she'll let her out
who let her out yeah yeah put her back
stop you have a hall pass ma'am yeah
ma'am
and so you should offer a house by
yourself
where's your husband you know husband
he's at home
you think you can sign these documents
young lady all by yourself no i
i don't know dude speaking of i i know i
brought it up but speaking of a ring i
had to take my ring off because your
fingers too fancy like
like first i had to take off my wedding
band because that fits me smaller and
then now my engagement ring doesn't fit
me anymore it's like two so i'm not
married anymore so i feel so naked yeah
i'm like
i'm married okay i promise no one's
cheating on you you should drop her out
line yeah
dude this is a complete opposite it's so
like sidetracking but with isaac when i
was pregnant with isaac i was 17 i
remember feeling so like ashamed that i
was pregnant yeah not married and like
so like shameful of that to the point
where like i almost bought myself a 25
cent like ring from like the coin
yeah just to like have a ring on there
just so i would feel like a little bit
better but i never did that and then now
i am married i am pregnant once again
and now i can't fit in my actual wedding
it's just like you never need to
experience to feel like a flashback um
it does feel like a flashback moment but
now it's like on a comedic level like
yeah it's funny
you're like i know i'm not 16 and
pregnant again okay
yeah sorry sidetracked but anyway it's
cute next one here it says talking to
yourself is a healthy habit that people
people get shamed for it says it's good
it's a good way to problem solve or even
just vent about something who even knows
that you're talking to yourself and
shaming someone about it
just put a camera in front of you this
is called vlogging
true do i know that you talk to yourself
like sometimes you know you can hear
themselves like talking to themselves so
like what comes up to mind for me is
so my dad i think i brought this up
before in the past but my dad used to
always talk to himself like under his
breath or whatever like giving him so
like i got to do this i got to do that
blah blah blah and when my parents
divorced like my mom just had so much
like resentment towards my dad so
anything that reminded her of my dad she
would be like crazy people do that so
then she she would say like crazy only
crazy people talk to themselves and then
one time she was driving she was like
talking to herself like saying things
and i'm like
mom are you crazy i remember you saying
that only crazy people can talk to
themselves and she was like
but that's kind of what i remember but
like there are people that judge people
for talking to themselves so then i
remember like having that like out loud
yeah like just i never really hear
people talking to themselves out loud do
you
does casey do it yeah sometimes or like
like i think once or twice in our entire
relationship i think i've heard you like
whisper something
that judges people for talking about
really
judges people i can't hear people
talking out loud i know you're talking
out loud i'm talking too loud
my thoughts are so loud it's the only
thing i'm paying attention to i'm not
listening to you talk to yourself you
know why i think i talk to myself
because there's so many thoughts in
there that i have to verbally say it and
say what i'm trying to focus on to shut
out the other oh you have 17
personalities yeah the same personality
just a lot of voices i'm like stop it
i'm trying to concentrate that's what
adderall helps with um
but i'll be like i'll lose i'll lose my
phone like i'm like i just just i was
just carrying it where did i put it i
put okay hold on we were in the room we
were in the podcast room okay good let's
go there no okay it's not there where
the [ __ ] did i put it okay so then we
walked to the bathroom and then like all
taken that doesn't seem weird to me yes
no okay do i do that
i don't even know if i'd talk out loud i
don't think i've ever caught myself i
don't think i talk out loud but it's
just gonna clarify thoughts yeah it's
the same i do the same thing in my head
i just don't do it out loud but
yeah i don't think that's weird yeah
meaning that i've only heard people talk
out loud because i feel like they're
trying to fill the void
oh that's a little different yeah i like
to like walk their thoughts out again i
don't think i've ever experienced that
so casey said that uh what did you say
he's stupid
and yeah he mad at him for now remember
what you just [ __ ] asked him for
[ __ ] put that on the table
remember when you [ __ ] get yelled at
me for not remembering what was just
said you forgot what was just like that
i had to say it no so casey said that
whenever uh he feels like that whenever
people are speaking out loud is to fill
the void so they don't have to like be
in silence
so you judge that i judge that because i
feel like it's performative like he
feels it's performative you have to get
attention to get it okay so if they're
around other people
yeah it's like the only way that you
would know someone speaks themselves if
they're around someone else and they're
just talking to themselves they're like
you're not talking to me but you're just
talking to the ether yeah and i'm like
i've never experienced that i find it
very interesting that that's your
perspective that you feel that other
people are being performed are they
performing for themselves do they know
you're there maybe they're trying to
strike a conversation without actually
striking out like are they at a table
like i get that
i get that yeah that's happened to me is
it like when you're like at a bus stop
or something like and someone's like
[ __ ]
can't even drive blah blah blah or like
they're talking about something and yeah
because that's happened before when i'm
standing next to someone and they start
commenting on the world around to no one
but like they're just waiting for
someone to like waiting to agree with
them
i hear that like there's that part but
then like the other part where it's just
like someone just talking or like
rambling their own thoughts out loud you
find that to be performative yes
oh interesting cause that's fine and
annoying
yeah
yes you could not live in my house
because i i hear that i hear that
perspective from you and i'm like
is that cause like if you were to do
that you're you're coming at it from
that perspective is it like a projection
thing that you view other people like
that maybe i think maybe when i get
awkward in silence i do do that so
that's where it's coming from the
judgment you're judging yourself
perhaps projection yeah yeah but then i
do judge other people that's my lens
that's that's why i think most most
judgments come from projections that
you're insecure about right exactly i
dated this guy who was really insecure
about his nose like he thought he had a
big nose but he would always talk about
other people's noses like oh my god look
at that big nose on that girl like oh my
god that girl has such a big that guy's
nose is huge or whatever and i'm like
dude
calm down yeah that's crazy that just
triggered me a little bit because i've
always i i've not liked my nose for so
long but every time i see someone's nose
even if they think it's ugly and they're
like i totally want to get a nose job
i'm like no but your nose is so pretty i
wish i had that one instead
that's weird though like we always
project our own judgments or
insecurities onto other people that's
such a fact that's why when you saw you
when you brought that up it it triggered
that for me where i'm like oh maybe
that's how you act like if you were to
speak out loud you end up
being performative and then you feel
cringe and then you're annoyed by
yourself or whatever that's interesting
yeah there's always it always circles
back to you yeah everyone's so about
themselves i'm trying to put that in
context of my ex rapper boyfriend like
you don't ever want to be cocky about
something you don't know anything yeah
that's what you value yeah knowledge and
all right next one on this list it says
going to bed early it's a healthy thing
that people get who are shame who's just
saying those people yeah this one says
i've been called an old lady many times
because i just get tired that's you
[ __ ] you know
you always go you always like want to
leave the club early you want to go to
bed i'm the only one
oh true i've just gotten so used to it
and i'm like you just don't care and
you're like it's my life i give a [ __ ]
if you want
i think i've been a 65 year old woman
since yeah i was like 22.
yeah so being 22 and then being like i'm
going to bed at 10 pm guys that was me
for sure peace out you don't remember
getting shame even well if i chose to
stay out with them i would just fall
asleep in the club or fall asleep at
some point
asleep in front of my body will just be
like no we're done yeah like yeah peace
i wish i had that
yeah
y'all are
jealous why people shave cause
i want to go home
i wish i could sleep no it's not about
staying out to be cool it's like i
literally can't sleep it takes me like
hours to fall asleep i was jealous of
you because i was like man i want to
stay up and party yeah
i'm so
what time do you wake up
like 7 30 or 8. it's so early no wonder
you're out
it's not even that early most people
wake up at like 6. that's early for me
okay yeah i wake up like at 8 nine after
we moved i was waking up at 10 every day
and i was like oh my gosh who am i are
you okay
no
and also i've been playing poker until
like 4 30 in the morning okay
you turn into gina darling yeah yeah i
was actually gonna ask her about that
like hey did you used to like
be kind of a daytime person in the
switch no she's always been like that
well now she's a daytime person yeah she
has a job
the other way
i'm a gamer
a degenerate card gamer now stay until
four in the morning so funny gotta get
it back gotta get even
i'll get it back
okay
chasing your losses yeah
all right next one it says being wrong
it's okay it's healthy it's healthy to
express opinions and ideas when we shame
people for being wrong we tend to stop
new conversations from happening yeah in
this way we lose opportunities to
understand where others are coming from
and squander opportunities to change
minds i love this so much because yeah
it's like it's okay to be like for other
people to be wrong but to shame them so
hard to the point where like now they
don't want to talk they don't want to
talk they're afraid like they're just
they feel dumb or whatever i relate to
that so hard because there was so many
times that i was wrong like on jk news
for example or like i'll get information
that was from an article that they ended
up revising after i already presented it
and then the information was incorrect
but then now it gets blamed on me
because i was the one reading from it
and i'm just like
dude like chill like it's not a big deal
like
yeah
you can find out the correct information
you could have a conversation in the in
the comments about it why does the shame
need to be on top of that or it's like
you incompetent [ __ ] idiot like what
is wrong with you like you can't do your
research properly i think again that's
what that's the projection thing it's
just like all the other things right
it's like they're afraid of getting
outed for being wrong and it also it's
just from people taking things too
seriously like people get so tunnel
visioned into like
like this thing that they're watching
and they just like blast off and they
don't really
they're not really like zooming out like
oh this is a person that i'm talking to
about like that this person has feelings
and this behind the screen they don't
really have the human connection i'm not
a trained journalist either like yeah
yeah
there's no context involved with that
yeah also the whole like shaming other
people for having different opinions
than you or a different perspective or
even if they are wrong i would much
rather hear all the reasons they believe
what they believe so that we can have a
discussion about it and then there's
discourse and and then i could let them
know like what i believe and why i
believe it and why i disagree with some
things and that's how you change
people's minds if they if they are to be
changed but you're not going to get it
by shaming them right i think people um
i'm like i've asked the question before
to people that go really hard on the
like no [ __ ] you you're wrong you know
i'm like are you scared of changing your
mind is that why you don't want to
engage and just genuinely like i'm just
curious at why people think that they
just
like once you make your decisions
if you want to change their mind like
just listen to what their points are so
that you can properly counteract those
points not like shun them out completely
yeah but i do think that there is a fear
involved that like it's could not be
contagious right
i might catch their opinion and
stick to it and they've made it part of
their identity yeah it is kind of weird
it's like
what's the what's at the root of it
what's wrong with being
wrong about something
it just shows
it's no but like what is it that we're
afraid of like is it it's signals so
pride first of all okay yeah and then
you don't want to be seen as incompetent
or stupid or get some kind of
branding on you that you're dumb
and then now
it's all that shame yeah you're not
you're not credible as a person anymore
because you're wrong about one thing so
now you're wrong about everything right
yeah but i think i mean yeah once you
get to a certain place where it's like
when you're willing to change your mind
based on new information then
you'd suddenly become more
trustworthy right because like if i was
to tell you something and you would
never [ __ ] change your mind on it i
would be like i don't know if i can i
don't think that they think they use
like critical thinking yeah and like
they're not willing to
so like it's okay that they were wrong
but now that that they have some sort of
other information they still won't admit
they're wrong now i feel like you're
even dumb like if you were just to be
like
yeah i guess maybe i was wrong on that
but if you won't even take the
information yeah
or anything yeah that to me i will judge
you harder than if you were wrong the
first time yeah you can be wrong the
first time we're all wrong about all
kinds of [ __ ] yeah exactly once again
everybody's full of [ __ ] nobody knows
what they're doing yeah i mean but the
main thing too is like the the fact
about
shutting the conversation down once
you're already like move past the part
where they're like a person is incorrect
like not even being able to move past
that and then still have to continue a
conversation where you can explore ideas
and just be like see you were wrong
you're [ __ ] wrong and then like
having that ego and that pride get in
the way oh that i told you something
yeah yeah i told i told you i think
maybe sometimes people aren't willing to
say that they're wrong because they feel
like the other person hasn't fully
gotten it too like because if i have
fully believed and consumed something
and i'm so
deeply like rooted in this thought or
this theory or whatever and you're like
you're still not getting it and i'm just
gonna be like no like no like no we
can't keep talking because you're just
not getting it so let's just stop
[ __ ] you know like i felt that before
but that's upsetting though
i just yeah i don't know i feel like
i've even had those conversations with
like people close to me or like family
members or something where i'm just like
they're so strong on one thing and i'm
like
no i just i don't even know where to
take this conversation because i just
feel like you're not even in my same
world you're not here you're not seeing
it or like you're so sold on your own
idea so then
there's that saying at what point do you
stop like once you know something your
brain shuts down to any other options
like once you decided you know something
yeah you're no longer open-minded to
anything and you you like actually don't
get to receive new information that
could help you learn or grow because
you've already decided that you know
something but not everyone's like that
though i don't think once you decide
that you know it it's very hard for you
to
get to get your mind changed
to any new information if you haven't
already decided when you're like okay
there's a good chance that this is the
thing okay then you're still receptive
but once you've decided nope i know that
this is it's almost like
you shaped that reality so now you're
you're stuck with yeah you can't you're
not even reset i think i just realized
that i'm not
okay i know on a lot of things i am very
staunch on but i think there's a lot of
things i'm not because i've changed my
mind about
a very large amount of things over the
last two years
that i felt pretty strongly about before
so maybe i just wasn't
that deeply rooted in them or i would
still
be like no no you're wrong nope yeah no
like absolutely you don't speak in
absolutes yeah like you're very
confident in your opinions and your
ideas but i also think that you'll take
what the other person is saying and
you'll do your own research on it like
you and you'll kind of process it and
digest it and like kind of soak a little
bit in it we've before just
point blank rejecting it yeah maybe
that's why i feel like i'm kind of like
a moderate person just even politically
too cause i'm like well i kind of agree
with some of these things and i kind of
agree with some of those things and then
i don't
i don't think i've completely shut down
that many things yeah because even the
things i feel very strongly about like
say abortion like they're right to have
an abortion or something getting deep
right i'm pro-choice but then i still
i'm like there's like a one percent of
me that's like i get why they don't want
us to have that option right but like i
still
feel like i want us to have that option
but i can a little bit i kind of see it
but then also no yeah you know i also go
[ __ ]
yourself a middle ground there where i'm
like hey once it's to like a certain
point yeah like obviously then i'm like
um kind of hard to make a document like
but you should you should have this
choice
yeah at least for a little bit yeah so i
guess it's hard for me to be a hundred
percent on really anything because
they're if someone else can have another
opinion then in my head i'm like well
there's a reason why right even though i
vastly disagree with you but i still get
why you feel that way yeah yeah
i think that's the important part is
validating like why someone would feel
that way like okay whether it's your
upbringing whether you had some like
trauma in your childhood that [ __ ]
your mentality up and now you like it's
like even people that hate things or
like that will like abuse puppies or
something like the most evilest people
you're like okay
what happened it came from
what happened to make you feel like this
is okay i'm never gonna agree with you
right it's okay to kill puppies but i
want to know and that's the only way
that we as a species i think find uh
solutions to these things where now we
know okay and
traumatizing childhood are more likely
to grow up to be serial killers like
there's like a lot of serial killers had
something that happened to them that
[ __ ] them up so let's try to take as
much prevention as possible protect our
children and have them not be
traumatized in childhood and there's
less likely a chance that they will form
some psychological disorder that makes
them violent yeah that's why um i
remember having a conversation with
casey before about this where i'm like i
don't feel anyone is born evil like i
don't feel like evil is created i think
everyone's susceptible to evil yeah but
yeah i don't think anyone's just like
born pure evil yeah such a weirdo yeah
that's a whole different episode
and i don't think they should be shaped
let's normalize evil okay
for most of us learning a second
language in high school or college
wasn't exactly a high point in our
academic careers now thanks to babel the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you'll be traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
family or you just have some free time
babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you'll actually use in the
real world i personally am studying
french with babble i only do it in the
evenings when i'm in the tub taking a
little evening bath because that's my
relaxed time and my time to fantasize
about going back to france
and i try to learn some words that i
could use that i could impress the boys
aka le gelsons anyways babel's 15 minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go other language
learning apps use ai for their lesson
plans but babel lessons were created by
over 100 language experts their teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective with babel you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german plus
babel's speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent there's so many ways to learn
with babble in addition to lessons you
can access podcasts games videos stories
and even live classes and it comes with
a 20-day money-back guarantee there is
no risk i love the babel user interface
i think the lesson plans um the graphics
just everything about it is basically i
think this is the best one on the market
and you can hold me to that you should
just give it a try if you're trying to
learn a new language try babble even
just for a short period of time give it
a shot start your new language learning
journey today with babel right now when
you purchase a three month babel
subscription you'll get an additional
three months for free that's six months
for the price of three just go to
babel.com and use promo code big mood
that's babb
el.com and use code mood babble language
for life online shopping isn't slowing
down anytime soon is your business ready
to keep up with the pace well with
shipstation you never have to worry
about shipping ever again you can make
the switch to a solution that handles
all your shipping needs quickly
affordably and painlessly save time by
funneling all your orders into one
simple interface no matter where you're
selling so if you're selling on amazon
ebay etsy your own website really like
anywhere even your phone like there's no
more headaches from dealing with the
returns and return tracking because ship
station makes it super super easy so if
you own a product-based business to save
your sanity knowing your orders are
handled and you are getting the best
rates you can make shipping the easy
part of having an online store you have
better ideas to think about they're
bigger they're better shipping what we
don't want to think about that no wonder
98 percent of companies that use ship
station for a year keep using it for as
long as they're in business i personally
love the ease of use i've saved a lot of
money with shipstation those two things
are priceless to me so ship more in less
time just use our code big mood to get a
60 day free trial that's two months free
of no hassle stress free shipping just
go to shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
type in big mood that's shipstation.com
enter offer code big mood and make ship
happen all right next one it says
bettering yourself i've seen people take
photos of overweight people in the gym
shaming them like seriously yeah that's
that's really like a kind of an immature
personality trait i mean you don't have
to be young to be a mature it's also i
don't think it's even just a maturity i
think it's um another like going back
like the projection yeah yeah
they are insecure yeah themselves and so
they have to shame other people and
that's how like high school bullies
that's literally their whole [ __ ]
thing where it's like oh i see something
in you that i either i wish i had or
that i see that i have and i'm gonna
shame you for that i'm scared
yeah and i'm just going to make you feel
shitty about it when i first read this
title of this list i that's the first
thing that i thought of like people who
are homophobic that are actually
secretly gay
they don't want to they want to just
deny that part of themselves exactly
yeah it really all circles back to you
yeah there was a video on there's like a
whole lot of like cringe compilation
stuff or like like just sites or
subreddits or whatever where you can
like see cringe stuff and sometimes it's
just like
maybe like a a quote-unquote overweight
person like just swimming in a pool and
like someone took the camera underwater
and you can kind of see their body like
moving like i saw this one video this
their bodies just like moving crazy
because they're very overweight right
and the water is just kind of like
rippling and then they're calling it
cringe but i'm like this person's just
swimming and then like yeah so it's like
bullying yeah
it's like that's probably the best way
for them to get exercise in the
beginning of their weight loss journey
is like in water it helps and like don't
shame that person for like going to go
swim like they're they're not being
cringed they're just [ __ ] swimming
yeah yeah trying to do something yeah so
that's i hate when i see that too but i
i think it's when like someone's doing
something where they're too cocky about
it where i'm like yeah you know what go
[ __ ] yourself yeah like those like some
like gym bros are like so cocky and i'm
like [ __ ] off they're way more cringed
yeah person's just trying to swim yeah
yeah i know but you know it's
interesting to explore too it's like if
it's a spectrum of like cocky to
insecure
like where is the like at what point do
we cross over the too far either yeah
either way it's like you want to be
semi-confident with what you're doing
you don't want to be super
self-conscious
yeah well being boastful i think is the
cockiness aspect that turns people off
it's like when you're you could be
confident but
projecting to the world like look at me
look up confident and i'm [ __ ] you like
i'm the best i'm the best you're the
worst when you're making it when you're
lowering others to boost yourself up
that's that's what it is that to me so
instead of it being a spectrum it's like
a circle because then to me like how
boastful they are that's how insecure
they are yeah yeah like the guys with
their big
you're like oh does he have a small
penis like why is this truck so big
yeah that's exactly what i think of like
i'm like oh it's okay yeah you don't
have to like over compensate it's all
right like it's okay it's cool you're
good it's all right
i end up seeing that as like mega
self-conscious super insecure like oh
people that are are just so yeah very
boastful but also very like do you see
how confident i am like i am so [ __ ]
confident and it's like oh they're so
insecure yeah
yeah because normally you don't have to
tell someone yeah like you don't have to
say you're you're super confident you're
such a whatever like now i guess i don't
know if it comes with age or experience
but now i see right through that where
it's like oh i could peel back the
curtain and see how small you feel like
i get a little bit of it is like fake it
till you make it like maybe someone
needs that in the beginning to like get
started but i think very soon after you
get started and start making a little
bit of a headway you should kind of
pretty quickly like grow out of that
yeah
and just be or just settle yeah settle
into you just keep doing it who you are
yeah you don't have to overcome like
keep selling maybe they're scared of
that yeah like who they really
[Laughter]
i enjoyed that yeah
okay next one on this list it says
estranging from toxic parents
can be healthy it's a healthy thing that
people get shamed for yeah that's a
tough one that's a real tough one
because everyone has their own opinions
based on their own relationships and and
so you never know how bad someone's
relationship is to where you saying like
oh just try to make it work is actually
very dramatic yeah right i would never
judge someone for a stranger from
because you don't yeah you really don't
know right like
maybe they're not telling you a lot
exactly what's the opposite or the
opposite is this is estranging from a
toxic parent like for that person in
particular they might find it more
hurtful to estrange themselves from
their parent for whatever reason and
they're trying to work i don't know like
i'm just trying to like they're acting
like their parents are so toxic but
really they're just being parents and so
they're kind of like i'm never talking
to you again because you want me to
actually do something with my life or
you know like they're just they're just
like trying to be parents and helpful
versus like actually
harming you and your psyche maybe
there's like a difficult thing between
kids and parents where they're like
you're being toxic but the parents are
like i'm just trying to help you yeah if
you don't want to do it okay you're
ruining my life the [ __ ] was that i
think there was a cat popping up a
little bit okay that's what i'm gonna
get
spot the balloon
like a [ __ ] little i was like is
there fireworks yeah it sounds like a
gunshot to me yeah it's not a really
good neighborhood house
but yeah so exchanging for from toxic
parents that one's really interesting to
me because like well i personally i
personally would agree with this yeah
yeah like i would cut my parents like
this like real quick if it really
reached to that point
but yeah like i guess i relate to the
opposite of it too where it's like well
you know there's a reason why parents
are the way they are or they've done
what they've done and then like they're
doing their best they're doing their
best there's like if they really are
right or if they're like really trying
to make amends for their past and
they're trying to like create a new
future and like yeah like i i get why
people are against
estranging from their parents yeah i
think the you have to define toxic like
you were saying because there's
definitely narcissistic parents that i
do think you should extremely damaging
it's really damaging to continuing
because they've trained you to be
codependent like it's hard for you to
break it off with them um and one of my
good friends um has this where
she
knows that her mom is like extremely
narcissistic and abusive but she also
whenever her mom's around she like can't
help but cater to her like she just it's
just this innate thing and there's no
way for her to like really sever it even
though when she's away from her mom
she's like oh i should really like
stop interacting with her yeah i can see
how it's hard i've never been in that
situation so i can't really but you were
saying that oh yeah yeah there was a
period where towards the end of my mom's
life like luckily i i got to talk to her
again right before she passed but
towards the end of her life there were a
couple years where i kind of just didn't
talk to her at all because she really
went off the deep end like she really
started to lose her [ __ ]
um and she actually kicked me out of her
house like this had never happened
before but we got into a disagreement to
the the la
one of the last times i had seen her
where she actually
i drove an hour to go see her and when i
got there we were talking for like 10 or
15 minutes and she literally kicked me
out of her house because we disagreed on
a certain subject and i was like okay
but it's not that [ __ ] serious and
she's like no i can't have someone that
thinks blah blah blah blah in my house
get the [ __ ] out and i was just like
looking at her like are you [ __ ]
kidding me like never in my life like so
she really degraded like mentally
towards the end but then
time so maybe a couple years went by i
didn't really talk to her and then
towards the end of her life when she
actually kind of lost it even more it's
almost like she forgot even that part of
herself so she was just kind of looking
at me like her daughter again so i did
get to kind of make some sort of piece
which not everyone gets right before she
passed but yeah there was time there was
a period in time where she really lost
her [ __ ] she went cuckoo
and so i just had to completely
disengage because it was literally
hurting me yeah on a daily basis and it
was affecting the way that i was
treating the people around me even just
because i would have to deal with her
and then i would be kind of like taking
on like who she was is like it reflected
on me and then so i was just angry that
like i am like a part of that or
something you know so yeah there's there
has to be a point
where it's
it weighs you down so bad that you just
have to let go and even if you just let
go for like maybe a year or two or just
something to kind of get your own
strength and like get your own
like feet you know
stable or something just to kind of
remember like you are your own person
and like you don't have to soak them in
constantly because it can be really
devastating yeah but yeah so i i
definitely agree like it was because i
never would disengage until something
just snapped i was like she [ __ ]
kicked me out like i'm gone yeah peace
out you know it reminds me of eminem oh
my god
with his mom you hear the song
headlights
probably you should hear that do you
want to wrap it for me
okay i will oh she actually
offered for you
okay next one not drinking every time
you go out with friends people get
shamed for that oh and it's a healthy
thing you don't have to drink your liver
can [ __ ] jump once junior's clearly
is no one's taking [ __ ] that seriously
yeah no one really sounds like a good
earlier
also if you're in a group of alcoholics
though they will shame you yeah i was
gonna say that too like a group of
people that like they need to have fun
with alcohol and if you
aren't engaging with alcohol like yeah
what's wrong with you that's a red flag
for me like if i'm in a group of people
and they're like you're not gonna
[ __ ] drink well get the [ __ ] out like
what are you doing we don't need them we
don't need the sober person [ __ ]
remembering everything we're doing
tomorrow it's like
okay you have a real issue with alcohol
and this is like not really a person
that i need to add to my friend's circle
yeah cause like if you enjoy me you can
enjoy me whether i'm drunk or not it
doesn't matter if you are or not like i
don't give a [ __ ] if you want to drink
those people that the dare program which
warned us again
you're going to eat pressure you're
going to get pressured
when i get to high school everyone's
going to pressure me to do drugs and i'm
like
no
yeah that's like super red flag though
yeah seriously okay next one as a man
using sunblock i can't even tell you how
many times i've been heckled on the golf
course for putting sunblock on my face
before being out in the sun for the next
four to five hours but the women love
you
you're like
i know
that's awesome that's one of the the
masculine [ __ ] things that we need
to cut out because you know men like
some men like one percent of men age
really well but then a lot of guys
because they do zero [ __ ] skin care
they drink too much sometimes they're
[ __ ] smoking cigars like do it they
do all this [ __ ] and they ate out in the
sun terribly ever never had
sunscreen on
never using lotion like in case he's
waving at me
yeah like take care of your skin please
no but like that that whole thing too
like because of that i guess stigma
would not be appropriate to label this
of like men caring for their skin then
men themselves judge themselves if they
try to take care of their own yeah
i feel like what happens now because
yeah cause then like casey would be like
oh my god i have all these sunspots and
like i have so many like new wrinkles or
whatever happening on my face i'm like
it's because you don't put sunblock and
so i'm always like just put some
sunscreen he feels like a little [ __ ]
because he put sunscreen on husbands
just don't put sunscreen on yeah even if
they get burned sometimes i'm like
you're a lobster
he does put it on because he goes hiking
every single morning though he will like
he'll come back home and he gives me a
kiss i'm like oh you can smell the
sunscreen good job yeah you're you're
doing it i think they don't want to be
like remember when mark zuckerberg had
that like white cast
dude that doesn't help they're afraid of
looking like a dumbass but you know who
puts on sunscreen that's masculine as
[ __ ] is surfers all these surfer guys
that i grew up around they all [ __ ]
put sunscreen on them
you know what they wear
and i don't even know if this is related
or just anecdotal but like
all the people i know that got skin
cancer are women who wear sunscreen oh
interesting but i'm like how come i've
never heard of a man getting sick
because they don't get diagnosed they
don't go to the doctor
that's true there we go
that's where it is we go to the doctor
we get diagnosed for it's just like
a random adventure like they died out of
nowhere yeah
he never went to the doctor in 40 years
yeah then they won't get the what is it
called when you're dead and they find
out how you died the autopsy that one
yeah autopsy like you won't get a knob
tossing yeah we don't need to find out
how jim died he went out like a man
yeah this next one is a man thing too
it's men crying it's healthy for men to
cry but there's like this shame around
it where it's like oh you little [ __ ]
you're crying or whatever like yeah i
really hope that this new generation
though because i think they are yeah
like they're growing they're evolving
they're being more like
emotionally open and like just very
conscious of like
the human um experience that i feel like
now it's not that prevalent of like
making men be
like feel shameful for feeling emotions
or saying i love you man or hugging or
whatever but like our generation and
before like it's really bad i everything
i've seen like on the internet at least
which i know isn't the best uh pool of
people but like all the jinzy youtubers
and stuff that i've watched all the men
seem very emotionally aware yeah so i i
feel like they're gonna they're in the
right direction yeah steve's been crying
during episodes um
more i mean not like all the time but
like
like once a year there'll be an episode
that he gets teary-eyed
yeah on my other pocket should they
don't tell you go watch it on any
platform no but um i felt almost the
opposite and well i got shamed a lot for
crying by my dad um when i was a kid but
uh and i'm a very emotional person and
it's just the way that any emotion comes
out of me like joy happiness i just get
an overwhelming amount of emotion and it
comes out through crying but i've always
been in fields that were pretty male
dominated and i feel like if i felt like
if i cried in front of them or like when
i was feeling emotional i had to hide it
because
then i would just get the the women
they're so emotional they're not like
logical or whatever and i was so scared
of like that taking away credibility
because i'm just emotional which has
nothing to do with like i'll be crying
and
telling saying logical things while i'm
crying it's just a way of getting rid of
um that extra tension in your body it's
really natural and really emotional is
very important no one can be purely
logical yeah be great and we're actually
more emotional creatures that's why i
think people that shame people for
having emotions is they're they're
scared they like to think oh i'm very
logical i'm very very logical and i
never have emotions oh my god and then
the people that think that they're the
most logical are the most emotional yeah
it just comes out in other ways that
they're not aware of like yeah they're
releasing that tension in other ways
that are probably even more damaging
yeah because they end up having anger
problems yeah which anger throws off
your judgment more than any other thing
it's the most damaging emotion to have
okay next one is minding your business
some people uh some perceive it as you
not liking them hmm
i guess they're probably saying like in
a situation where it's a group setting
or something i don't know i'm trying to
think of an example yeah like if you're
keeping too much to yourself yeah then
people think that you don't like them
like you're like anti-social i guess it
could come off anti-social i mean it is
a part of the culture to to gossip right
it's always been so i guess if you don't
take if you don't want to
involve yourself in that kind of thing
and you just want to mind your own
business and maybe people are like why
don't they [ __ ] want to be a part
what a fuddy daddy why don't weren't
they never heard of that
it's white yeah you're not white
yeah it's your right side it's my
what is it explain
it's like when you're party pooper oh
like you're like poo pooing on
everyone's good times
[Laughter]
it's like she's never heard english
before i've never heard this term in my
life have you heard the term this one
this one
gets some laughs sometimes getting
gussied up yeah no i've never heard of
the southern white thing though you
don't speed up getting like getting
[Laughter]
he's been around that's a little deep
that's a little deep in the white coat
which is like very southern really deep
yeah the southern belle i didn't know
you went that deep in our in our
whiteness you know
i actually have family from georgia oh
geez that's why i'm like pretty white
okay
sometimes
like this is like my minority side
i'm in the middle
spectrum
okay i'll be the filipino representation
you're like
a dark side it's all spanish anyway
that's true spanish blood is this whole
white people think because my mom says
it's a lot too she's like honey don't
let them get your goat
get your goat yeah i've never heard that
okay your mom is [ __ ] weird
what is get your go like like i don't
let them like don't let them bother you
like like bring you down like yeah
exactly like your your prized goat like
don't let them go
no i haven't heard you
go yeah that's a different kind of way
full of her for that those are the
appalachian whites or something that's a
different this is a different kind of
white also when she sit down at a
restaurant she's like i need i need
something to wet my palette
yeah i've heard that i've heard that
okay interesting
like w each eight sorry w-h-e-t
what is it
i think i just thought she wanted a
drink
what's that word um look maybe you can
google it really quick what does it mean
see if you can google w-h-e-t i could be
making this up i could be wrong but type
in your appetite type in to sharpen to
make it more
yeah oh interesting so that's not really
like a white trash thing that's just
like a thing
it's just a regular just a regular thing
yeah any race can say any race can say
that yes to wet your power
all right and that's uh that's our
episode you guys thank you for watching
i actually want to know
what have you guys been shamed for let
us know and you don't think you should
be shameful
where it's like wait why like this is a
healthy habit why am i being shamed for
this let us know in the comments
actually i have one
well i don't know if i'm being shamed
for it i'm not being ashamed for it but
a healthy habit is like bragging right
now actually what i do is
no no but like something that i think is
healthy
um is not being on social media so much
oh yeah but it's like part of my job so
yeah so like i you're self-shaming
because you're not doing it exactly and
self-shaming exactly so this this job is
not healthy so you're on the right track
it does matter your mental a lot yeah
that's definitely taking a lot of time
off like sharing like sharing like
throughout this whole pregnancy i've
been kind of like pretty much am i
that's true
and most people are like i'm pregnant
yeah
yeah like so much
i'm in a little bath
milk bath
yeah but like i don't know i'm just like
i'm i got over it like i don't know like
i'm just so i see that's very healthy i
see social media and i'm like that's a
chore
yeah that's why i chose to literally go
be an accountant i'm so jealous
[Music]
all right guys well thank you for
watching make sure to rate us on itunes
five stars that's super helpful for this
podcast also what's super helpful is if
you can visit our sponsors and show us
support through to say you found them
through us just visit the link at least
yeah go check out and share with your
friends share the episode with your
friends if you related yeah and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you